and welcome to today's best conference
with Karen Hogan the auditor general of
Canada on the reports table this morning
and welcome to this press conference
with Kieran Hogan auditor general of
Canada regarding the report Table this
morning uh we will have a few remarks
from the auditor general and then we'll
go for a question period so if you are
listening on Zoom please use the raise
hand function during the press
conference and we'll come to you after
the questions in the room downstairs
if you are on Zoom please use the raised
hand function
during the press conference and we will
give you the floor after the few
questions in the room here to you
um the uh Here's to You editor General
thank you
good morning and thank you for joining
me
I want to begin by acknowledging that we
are gathered on the traditional unseated
territory of the Algonquin and ishnabe
people
today I will be discussing the results
of our two most recent covid-19 audits
this brings to 11 the number of coveted
related reports that we have delivered
since the onset of the pandemic in
Canada more than two years ago
the nine covid-19 audits we delivered in
2021 looked at the government's actions
to respond to the pandemic and at
whether Federal organizations were
prepared to deal with a large-scale
public health emergency
with the audits we are releasing today
the focus of our work is Shifting to
look at how Federal departments and
organizations manage programs and
services for Canadians as the pandemic
continued to evolve
our first audit examined how the federal
government procured and distributed
vaccines to the provinces and
territories to immunize Canadians
against covet 19.
in Canada public health is a shared
responsibility between the federal
government the provinces and the
territories
we found that the public health agency
of Canada and health Canada supported by
public services and procurement Canada
work together to respond to the Urgent
nature of the pandemic
they obtained covid-19 vaccines so that
everyone in Canada could be immunized as
quickly as possible
public services and procurement Canada
established Advanced purchase agreements
with seven companies that showed
potential to develop viable vaccines
signing these agreements increase the
chances that Canada would secure enough
vaccine doses to support the largest
immunization program in the country's
history
recognizing that this approach also
meant that Canada could end up with a
surplus of doses if all vaccines were
eventually approved
salty Canada
Health Canada adjusted its usual
authorization process to speed up the
regulatory approval of covid-19 vaccines
between December 2020 and may 2022. the
federal government paid for 169 million
doses of vaccines
over 84 million were administered to
eligible people across the country
and so by the provinces and territories
on average the public health agency of
Canada delivered vaccines within two
days of receiving a province or
territory's request
this is successful considering the
logistics of transporting temperature
sensitive materials to sometimes remote
locations
while the organizations involved were
successful in securing vaccines and
quickly Distributing them to the
provinces and territories the public
health agency of Canada's efforts to
minimize wastage were unsuccessful
by the end of May 2022 Canada had 32.5
million doses of covid-19 vaccines
estimated to be worth about 1 billion
dollars in federal provincial and
territorial inventories
another 50.6 million doses were deemed
Surplus and offered for donation
we found that the agency's ability to
reduce wastage was affected by delays in
implementing important functionalities
of vaccine connect the information
technology system meant to help manage
covid-19 vaccines
we also found that the public health
agency did not have finalized data
sharing agreements with the provinces
and territories as a result it struggled
to effectively share detailed case level
safety surveillance data with health
Canada the World Health Organization and
vaccine companies
we raised concerns about the sharing of
Health data between Federal and
provincial or tutorial territorial
Health authorities in 1999 in 2002 2008
and again in our 2021 audit of pandemic
preparedness
these long-standing issues including
implementing a pan-canadian framework
for sharing information must be urgently
addressed because the sharing of Health
Data is a Cornerstone of effective
surveillance to keep Canadians safe
I'm going to turn now to the second
audit we released today
it focused on several covid-19 support
programs for individuals and also looked
at the Canada emergency wage subsidy
which provided support to employers
all these programs are measures that the
government put in place to minimize the
impact of the covid-19 pandemic on the
health of Canada's population businesses
and economy
overall we found that the Canada Revenue
Agency and employment and Social
Development Canada effectively delivered
covid-19 programs to to provide quick
Financial relief to individuals and
employers affected by the pandemic
in this way they serve to prevent an
increase in poverty and income
inequalities and helped the economy
bounce back
in 2020 the government decided to rely
on information provided by applicants
and limit prepayment controls to
expedite helping people and employers
affected by the pandemic
in doing so it recognized that there was
a risk that some payments would go to
ineligible recipients
we found that overpayments of 4.6
billion dollars were made to ineligible
individuals
and we estimated that at least
27.4 billion dollars of payments to
individuals and employers should be
investigated further
the Canada Revenue Agency and employment
and Social Development Canada recognized
the need for increased post-payment
verification work with the early
decision to limit prepayment controls
as the pandemic continued to evolve the
post-payment verifications were delayed
the number of post-payment verifications
included in the plans is insufficient to
address all payments at risk of being
ineligible
the agency and the department are not
planning to verify payments made to all
identified recipients who may not be
eligible for covid-19 benefit programs
efforts to collect amounts owing have
been limited to date and focused mostly
on prompting voluntary repayments
the Canada Revenue Agency had recovered
approximately 2.3 billion dollars
I am concerned about the lack of rigor
on post-payment verifications and
collection activities
the Canada Revenue Agency unemployment
and Social Development Canada we need to
act now to expand their post payment
verification plans to include all
recipients identified as being at risk
of being ineligible for benefits in the
department and the agency need to carry
out their plans and recover covid-19
benefit amounts owed
foreign
the pandemic prompted the creation and
delivery of income support programs
never seen before in Canada
many were up and running in a matter of
weeks where normally it would have taken
months or even years
though government organizations knew in
2020 that they would need to undertake
significant post-payment work down the
road
they have not adjusted their resources
or plans to deal with the long-term
effects of vast Income Support programs
that were rolled out in record time
billions of dollars have gone or may
have gone to ineligible recipients
to preserve the integrity and fairness
of Canada's tax system the government is
required under current legislation to
take action
if it chooses a different approach then
it must be clear and transparent with
Canadians
thank you for your attention I am now
ready to answer your questions
thank you merci if you are attending on
Zoom please use the raise hand function
at this point to ask a question
we'll start with questions in the room
we'll start with
from the Canadian press hi
um my first question is about uh the
report on the covet benefits
um I'm wondering if you could talk you
could compare a little bit uh the
benefits for individuals versus
businesses uh which do you see were more
successful
um uh in their in their delivery and
also uh verification and just as a whole
um so when it came to the benefit
programs we found overall that they were
quite effective in meeting the
government's objectives of first getting
uh support out to individuals and
employers quickly minimizing
um the increase in poverty or income
inequalities and also helping the
economy bounce back from the pandemic so
that would lump in both the individual
and support to employers when I divide
them up throughout the pandemic what we
saw is that the government tried to
adjust and add some additional
prepayment controls and made
modifications to the programs linked to
individuals but really missed those
opportunities when it came to the
business support what we found is that
even though the program kept getting
extended for the wage subsidy there was
no addition of prepayment controls which
would have minimized the need for rather
lengthy and complex post payment work
really related to to businesses when it
comes to recovery I think that was the
last part of your question I would say
they're at such early stages in both
individual and employers that it is too
early to tell that's why we recommended
much more rigorous plans that was the
commitment that both of the Departments
made following my first audits in 2021
that they would put in place
comprehensive post payment plans and
we're just not seeing that happen right
now thank you and my follow-up question
is about uh the other reports on behalf
of my colleague but um she's wondering
if you could be a little bit more
specific about you know how to prevent
wasted doses in the future
mm-hmm
uh well there's been many
recommendations following H1N1 and SARS
and even the first report I released on
pandemic preparedness that talked about
the need to not only resolve data
sharing agreements across provinces and
territories to have a more timely and
informed response but also to have the
technology needed to support that
vaccine connect was something that was
put in place during the response the
rollout of these coveted vaccines which
really they could have had a better
system in place earlier if they had
implemented all of the functionalities
of vaccine connect that could have
helped identify Supply needs and when
vaccines were likely to expire and move
them around more effectively which would
have minimized potential potential
wastage
thank you the next question is Canada
you said that you're concerned by an
amount of 27 million dollars for
benefits that's a lot of money
could you explain what should have been
done
to ensure that these funds were well
spent or that they're able to be
recovered and is it too late to recover
that money you talked about 36 months
that's not a lot of time is it too late
to recover those amounts
there were overpayments of 4.6 million
dollars for people who were not eligible
follow-up is being done now by
departments and we believe that there's
about 27.4 million dollars that needs to
be investigated
where the post payment verifications
need to be done by the government
we identified indicator indicators that
certain individuals and businesses were
not eligible for the amounts that they
received what concerns me is that the
plans are not exhaustive they don't
include all activities and they don't
include a follow-up to see if
individuals and businesses are eligible
we need to start there
and see if recovery is needed afterwards
currently in the legislation
there is a time frame for individuals of
36 months
misinformation that was shared and for
businesses it's about 36 to 48 months
that's why I was expecting that post
payment activities would start and we
recommended that they should be
more exhaustive before that deadline
um
for vaccines
30 million doses were wasted that was at
May 31st accordingly do you believe that
that number will increase significantly
you've noted that there are many doses
that
will be expiring by the end of the year
so will this number increase
significantly
that is a question
that I asked the public health agency of
Canada
I asked them to tell me what happened
with the doses following our audit the
department confirmed that there are 11
million doses that have expired
and so the number of doses
that have not been used
could expire
even
with the doses
that's why we recommended That vaccine
connect should be implemented in order
to better manage vaccines and to
minimize waste in the future see next up
Brian National Post
yeah hi there on on vaccines I'm
wondering overall you've talked about
some of the logistical issues and and
the the tracking Etc that the government
could have done better
but having ordered seven different
vaccines and tens of millions of doses
in advance was this level of wastage
unavoidable once all these vaccines were
delivered and and worked um
as well as the government expected I
guess
I mean that's a it's a great question
now to sit here and and look back and
think of what happened and I would
invite all of us to try and put
ourselves back in March of 2020
um and the environment that was going on
then when the government entered into
advanced purchase agreements uh there
was a a global rush to develop a vaccine
no one knew which vaccine companies
would develop viable vaccines which
would then be approved for use in Canada
um and the and there was a large Global
demand where Canada doesn't have any
manufacturing capabilities for those
vaccines so in my view the approach that
the government took to enter into
Advance purchase agreements was a
prudent one
um they knew that that would result in
excess vaccines or Surplus vaccines
being available which is why there was a
commitment to make donations But there
again so many countries were trying to
donate and that market saturated
resulting in the in the Canadian
government not being as successful as
they could but in my view it was a
prudent approach given all the
uncertainty back in 2020 and and now
we're able to look back and and see the
results of those decisions okay just a
follow-up for a colleague
in terms of the the overpayments of the
service serve and other benefits uh do
you have an estimation of how much of
those overpayments are the result of
sort of good faith Mistakes by Canadians
and how much are fraud and do you have
an estimate of how much you think the
government can realistically expect to
recover from that process
unfortunately I can't give you an answer
to either either of those questions
because of the limited information
that's available at the Canada Revenue
Agency right now when it came to
individuals uh the the 2019 and 2020 tax
returns are now available they weren't
available earlier on which is why we've
identified some payments that require
further investigation that I feel pretty
confident are ineligible but in order to
really give you know take the more
prudent approach of of giving the
benefit of that to the taxpayer we've
identified them as needing follow-up
when it comes to the businesses there
was very little information that was
collected on a monthly basis and so
without post payment verification it
would be almost impossible to know
the ability to recover or not or even to
identify with greater certainty what
went to in an ineligible businesses
which is why much more rigorous post
payment work is needed from the
government
thank you next up Bill Curry global
hi thanks for taking our questions the
follow-up on the 27 billion one of your
recommendations is the government should
more aggressively pursue that and you
describe it as a minimum amount that
could be more than that the government's
response is that they only partially
agree to that recommendation and they
make the argument that it uh is likely
not cost efficient to go after all of
that money so what is your reaction to
their response to that
uh well I obviously stand by my
recommendations and and I base my
recommendations on two things following
our 2021 audit on the candid emergency
response benefit and the Canada
emergency wage subsidy the Department's
committed to rigorous post payment work
and so I was expecting to see that
happening now and and it is just not
happening to the degree that I believe
it should be given the very limited
prepayment controls that were available
that were used at the start of these
programs
um the second is I would point to
existing legislation that requires that
every Canadian taxpayer be treated
fairly and that if the an individual or
business receives something they're not
entitled to it should be returned uh so
our expectation is that anyone who has a
high indicator of potentially being
ineligible should be investigated
further the decision then about recovery
is one that I encourage the government
to to to be transparent about what they
decide to do if they want to for perhaps
forgive payments or take a compassionate
approach then they should just be clear
and transparent with all Canadians what
to expect
um
I think for memory it's pretty unusual
for a government to not fully accept a
recommendation I could be wrong or not
but
um in the back and forth had they at any
point rejected outright that
recommendation can you kind of talk
about the back and forth that went into
that
um no I so I think many most departments
like to agree to our recommendations I'm
not sure that their written answer then
supports that agreement but
um that's that's another issue for us to
deal with
um here the back and forth that we had
was very clear they felt that they
didn't have their resources or them or
or the ability to follow up with
everyone identified as ineligible but
again I base it on fairness to all
taxpayers I'm sure there are individuals
out there who are wondering will I be
asked to repay will I be able to repay
and that's where I encourage that their
plans should just be made clear to
Canadians so that um every every
individual in business knows what to
expect
that will never be able to
recovery this is a question that I won't
be able to answer
I don't know
of an individual's or a company's
capacity to refund funds there were 4.6
billion dollars that were sent to
recipients that were ineligible for the
27 billion dollars that's a minimum
amount because there are other
eligibility criteria that we were not
able to verify and that's why the
government can identify can only
identify the sums if they do a vigorous
post payment assessment
second question there's a big difference
between 5 billion and 27 billion how can
that be explained
for the 4.6 billion dollars those are
payments
to individuals at the beginning of the
pandemic that were paid
that were duplicated rather
people were supposed to receive one
benefit at a time and there was a little
bit of confusion at the beginning
individuals were sending
an application to
esdc and to the CRA and they received
two payments and those are cases that
you absolutely need a follow-up
for the rest it's estimates or
information that is missing at the CRA
so that's that's what's left from all
the other programs global
um you've said that the programs of the
the money programs were effective in
meeting the government's objectives but
considering the amount of money that's
kind of unaccounted for here in terms of
whether or not it was appropriately paid
out do you think the programs themselves
were effective
um so we concluded they were effective
in meeting the objectives which which I
would summarize high level as getting
funds out quickly to individuals and
businesses minimizing an increase in
poverty or income inequalities across
the country and also allowing businesses
to maintain that relationship with their
employees and rebound once the economy
reopened that was effective there's lots
of Statistics in our report from
statistics Canada that demonstrate them
I would argue that they were inefficient
in that the the decision early on to
limit pre uh payment
controls knowing that there would be
payments made to ineligible individuals
has now resulted in in billions of
dollars going to ineligible individuals
or potentially going to an eligible
individuals and that's why the the hard
work is now needed when you minimize
prepayment to do rigorous post payment
work to identify who is really
ineligible and then make decisions about
recovery three just in English someone
to my colleague's question it is a big
gap between 4.7 and 27. why is there
such a wide Gap there from your
perspective so the 4.6 billion dollars
that we identified that was to
ineligible individuals really relates to
the start of the pandemic where um
mostly I would assume because of
confusion individuals applied to both
the Canada Revenue Agency and employment
and Social Development Canada to receive
the same benefit for one period so all
of the individual income support
programs and individuals only allowed to
receive one benefit per period so that
doubling up is is the 4.6 billion
dollars for the most part the rest for
now we're talking about all the other
covid programs as they continue to go on
versus just the first few months of of
the pandemic so that explains the the
large difference in the two buckets of
funds that we identify
have you been able to identify that lack
of rigoration
firstly the plans are not exhaustive
they don't
contain all of the activities
and don't include activities
all payments having a risk indicator are
going to receive a follow-up that's
where there's a lack of rigor
um
and they confirmed that delays were
caused by the pandemic and that's why we
recommended
that they do more work soon
because of the time that they have to
identify
if payments were made to ineligible
recipients
those two departments that you mentioned
in the reports
there was a lot of changing stuff a lot
of new hires could that have played a
role
in the dynamic and in the results
[Music]
we didn't look at
the individuals or resources at the
Departments I believe that having an
exhaustive plan would have helped them
determine their needs for resources and
time that's why you need a comprehensive
plan
but we did not look at
public servants and capacity
specifically thank you we're now going
to move to questions on Zoom we have
quite some time so
um that's good we're on course to answer
them all
first up Emily
would have increased the rigor
again I believe that the decision made
at the beginning of the pandemic
[Music]
best practices
was a good decision
but that comes with a need to have a lot
of post payment verifications
I would have liked to see that the
government
I would have liked for them to have made
adjustments during the pandemic for
example when the wage subsidy was
extended multiple times or following our
audit in 2021 they could have
implemented more bigger before
plan that is more exhaustive
[Music]
the the
TPS they had information
GST in order to identify payments that
were possibly ineligible
um
they have similar verifications
in other programs and so I was expecting
to see more Vigor this time
data sharing system between the federal
government and the provinces you say
that this problem is not new that it's
been an issue since 1999. that it
urgently needs to be fixed
Canada is it caused by the public safety
department in Canada
where is the problem in the system
I wouldn't be able to tell you if it's
the federal government or other levels
of government
as you know health is a shared
responsibility between the different
levels of government
of a pan-canadian agreement to share
data
is something
we have raised for over 25 years as an
issue
and I wonder how many other health
crises do we need as a country before we
find a solution to that data sharing um
we need to improve our health system in
Canada in order to help Canadians and
that is why I made a recommendation for
the government to move forward and
conclude the Penn Canadian data sharing
agreement
following questions
I was wondering if you had any
information on data sharing with Quebec
I cannot see what happens with the
provinces I only looked at the federal
government and they don't have an
agreement and that is why I made a
recommendation to the government to work
on that
so there is no agreement
we don't have information on how it's
going with the process my second
question has to do with the CRA they
announced last week that they wanted to
recover 3.2 billion dollars of
overpayment over payments
is it too late because of that time
frame of
I think that there's still time to
please identify overpayments or
ineligible payments to individuals or
businesses
and once the government has
identified these people they could
recover
the amount because not all payments were
sent out at the beginning of 2020. so I
would encourage them to start this is
do you know how much time they have left
answer not with any certainty but I
think that the first payments were sent
out in April 2020 so 36 months next up
is coming shortly
foreign
yes go ahead again okay awesome
yeah so um you said in your conclusion
that you're uh you're expecting
significant unrecoverable amounts are
likely to materialize with respect to
the the benefits that were paid out why
have you come to this conclusion why
aren't you confident that the government
will will claw back all the money that
was paid out to ineligible people
um so I I think I ended my closing
remarks but there's a possibility that
that be the case
um the uh the government needs to First
according to the current legislation
identify and notify individuals and
there is a legislative limit to that
time frame uh in order to be able to
notify individuals and businesses if
they have received amounts that are
ineligible
um my my advice to them is if they
wanted to make a decision then about
recovery one that might either forgive
payments or be empathetic then that's
something they should be clear and
transparent to with Canadians but
current legislation would require them
to follow up with those individuals and
recover those amounts
and you mentioned in the report
that there's actually relatively few
cases have been referred to the
authorities to the police for fraud or
identity theft do you think you know is
it fair to say that there was likely a
lot more criminality around these
programs that has just gone undetected
um unfortunately I could not um confirm
that uh again a lot of information not
being collected at the beginning of the
program
leads to the need for post-payment work
to confirm uh eligibility factors when
we did see instances where there was
potential fraud we ensured that the
agency had either taken proper action
and or referred them to the authorities
and didn't do any further work in order
not to get in the way of that
investigation
foreign
hey thank you very much um I just want
to Circle back on something you
mentioned uh in French I think it was to
Louise question earlier
um about vaccine wastage since the end
of May uh I guess from the inventory of
32 and a half million that that was
sitting in various government
inventories uh was that correct in
hearing that you said another 11 million
have since expired and if so do you have
an idea of what what the size of that
inventory is now as we're a few weeks
away from the end of the year
um so this is where I should have put my
glasses on when I answered the first
question
um to to be accurate with you
um those were donated I think the
question there was about donations
originally so on an extra 11 million had
been donated after year end so on my
apologies if I did misspeak
um expired
um afterwards um after well not after
your end after the end of our audit
which was May there was an additional I
would say about
um
10 10 million or so doses that have
expired since
um and this is exactly why we
recommended That vaccine connects needs
to be put into place and it's full
functionalities be used
um we even pointed to some of the data
really not being very solid data and
having errors in it as the country
continues to buy doses whether they be
violent doses or others it it makes
sense to have a better handle on where
the inventory is and better management
controls to avoid minimizing you know
wastage in the future but there is some
doses both included in inventory and
those available for donation that have
since expired since the end of May
okay thanks it was probably my French
maybe not your mistake although the
transcript will tell I guess
um so but an additional 10 million
basically expired so we're talking about
you know
24 or 23.6 million doses expired I I
guess in terms of the donations uh I
know the report kind of touches on this
I'm wondering if you can expand on this
um what did you learn about the
difficulties the government has had in
in actually you know with these Surplus
doses that are sitting there donating
them to other countries that need them
um will the governor the Canadian
government like many governments made a
commitment to donate certain doses to to
foreign countries
um there were some logistical
complications in trying to do that the
age um the shelf life remaining on some
of the vaccines at times uh caused some
difficulties but really the biggest was
the saturation of the donation market so
many other countries were donating
um that Canada just couldn't ship all
the ones they intended to ship
thank you next up Chris narzi National
Post
good good morning
um I'm just wondering um as you know CRA
has been doing Audits and verifications
for the better part of many decades now
and uh arguably has a lot of experience
in that
um so I'm wondering if you were
surprised when you were going through uh
their process and their post
verification protocols surprised by how
disappointed ultimately I read that you
are and how
you know lackluster are not very
thorough that they are was that
surprising to you considering the
agency's experience
well I think that the pandemic is really
an unusual time and the responses uh
require an unusual level of work
um so what we found was that Canada
Revenue Agency was was taking its
typical approach of a risk-based and
sampling and in in our view that is just
not rigorous enough when you have such
limited prepayment controls
um and and I think this is why um two of
our recommendations are really key in
the audit about the government advancing
its plans and projects to have a
real-time revenue and real-time payroll
information systems available going
forward Not only would this just improve
the Integrity of Canada's tax system and
have better information on hand it would
improve the efficiency and effectiveness
of any future income programs that might
be needed should the country have to go
through a similar Health Emergency in
the future
and and just to Circle back as well to
Bill Curry's questions on the kind of
semi-agreed upon a recommendation
um CRA says basically it wouldn't be
particularly efficient to try to go and
recoup every single dollar that was
overpaid
um whereas you say well you should at
least make you know a strong effort to
get as much as you can do you get the
sense that the agency is just trying to
kind of set the bar relatively low so
that it can't disappoint as opposed to
actually make the maximal effort and get
the maximal recovery
um unfortunately I can't tell you really
what the agency is thinking when they
decided to to partially agree with my
recommendation I'd encourage you to to
ask them
um you know my job is to hold them
responsible for delivering programs
within the current legislation and
within what I believe are the best
practices when you have limited
prepayment controls you have rigorous
comprehensive post payment work that is
needed to verify eligibility
the last question that I see on Zoom so
if you are listening on zoom and want to
ask a question it's time to use the
raise hand function at this moment so
last question is
from politics today
hi Miss Hogan thanks for taking our
questions
um in in sort of the early days of the
pandemic there was a lot of talk around
the cost of individual vaccines and the
government often said that you know it
couldn't specifically say because of
commercially sensitive info
um and that it could hinder their
ongoing or future negotiations with
other manufacturers can you speak to
whether or not that's something you came
across too
um I know that the average cost for
vaccines and your report is listed at
about 30 30 but that's as of May this
year so uh so I'm just wondering whether
or not there were other estimates that
you had or do you think those numbers
may be fluctuated dramatically
uh so throughout our audit we actually
had access to all of the advanced
purchase agreements and amendments to
them but we too have to respect the
confidentiality Clauses that were
included in those contracts and can't
provide a lot of details about
um the vaccines and the vaccine costs
but I knew that Canadians and
parliamentarians would want to to have
an idea of the estimate of the cost of a
vaccine and so what we did was use
information that was publicly available
so all of the payments to vaccine
companies through the Public Accounts of
Canada and then the 169 million doses
that we saw the the government had paid
for during our audit period so I can
tell you that I'm confident it
approximates the average cost of all the
doses that the government has paid for
but I would caution that that's at a
point in time as more doses are received
that number can fluctuate up and down
for an exchange will play a factor so it
really is just to give sort of a
benchmark Mark to individuals on the
cost average cost of a vaccine as of May
of 2022.
thank you
excuse me go ahead for your
um other question yeah sorry just as a
follow-up and I don't want to be sort of
all alarmist here just I guess moving
forward to Future emergencies or in case
of the future pandemics does does the
nature of these negotiations or maybe
the lack of some information make it
difficult for for you or government to
kind of hammer out which companies are
you know the best or maybe most cost
effective ones um yeah
well I don't think it's unusual to have
such confidentiality Clauses in the
pharmaceutical industry
um but you know these were really
unusual times and what was going on in
2020 is something that really had never
been seen the global demand the global
race to find a vaccine and so all of
those played into
um you know the factors that that ended
up being terms and conditions of these
contracts but I was not hindered my
office had full access to all the
information
a short one of questions since we have
some time left if it's okay with you my
name is
calculations on the 27 billion dollars
probably ineligible
it's not very clear because at page 23
of your reports
as to why these amounts are ineligible
do you believe that
we could talk about it
8.3 billion dollars sent to ineligible
recipients
ineligible companies why do you make the
distinction can you explain it please
detailed the calculations to show that
it's complex there's a lack of
information at the CRA
for us to conclude with certainty that
these amounts are ineligible
individuals they would be eligible if in
the 12 months before
the application that they had received
five thousand dollars
but tax returns are on a calendar year
so the information salary per month is
not available and that is why we
recommended that having a system with
real-time information
would very would be very useful for the
future for businesses now as I mentioned
there was no information collected
monthly
revenues
and this information does not exist at
the CRA
except for sales taxes and again that's
only
businesses that show that on a monthly
basis
so there's a lack of information
and that's why we say that these are
high risk indicators and the government
needs a more in-depth follow-up
in the government's response they say
that the high-risk indicators were
verified but what you're what you were
saying is that there are other high-risk
indicators that were set aside the GST
for example
yes because we looked at um
all of the businesses that send in their
provincial tax sales on a monthly basis
we believe that the government sample is
too small and that is why we recommend a
more exhaustive approach for post
payments few uh extra questions I saw a
little little fingers I start with the
build perhaps for uh so in a follow-up
you made a comment saying if the
government wanted to waive payment
obligations for reasons of empathy they
should say so
um if the government went down that road
because presumably when you look at your
report a lot of the people who receive
these benefits are some of the lowest
income people in Canada some are
ineligible because they didn't even have
5 000 in income the threshold according
to your report so if they were to make
that argument what would your take
beyond that
um I I I'm not the one who said Salah or
or makes those kind of policy decisions
but I absolutely think it would be a
reasonable approach but I encourage them
to be clear with Canadians right I think
one of the greatest things about our
country is you can expect
um fairness and and transparency and I'm
just asking the government to be clear
with its decisions and its approaches to
Canadians right now the legislation
would require them to follow up with
every uh individual in business that is
ineligible
down by size of company there's a pretty
sizable percentage as five employees or
less uh are you trying to Signal
anything by breaking that down should
were you more concerned about
particularly small companies or is there
is any section more high risk I guess of
no not at all I think what we were
trying to demonstrate there's a lot of
demographics in the back end of our
audit report was to show that
individuals and businesses that needed
support the most received it now it's
about identifying if there are those
um that were ineligible for the for for
the benefits and and making a decision
about recovery so it was really just to
help everyone understand uh where the
funding went
um whether it was across provinces or
across sizes of businesses
Ryan
[Music]
um
tens of billions of dollars spent on
very little follow-ups
simple questions management
[Music]
worthy of a G7 country
in normal times I would say no
but we are not in normal times
at the beginning of the pandemic
was very new
the government
um
that was different and they need to have
a different approach for their follow-up
now as well
if they decide not to recover these
amounts it's up to them but they should
be clear and transparent to Canadians
I'm just wondering as well you know the
government has made additional vaccine
purchases probably since your audit the
bivalent boosters and things like that
were you able to look at those contracts
on a go forward basis to know if the
government is putting better controls in
place so the remote we will won't be
more wastage going forward because we
know there hasn't been a big takeout for
example in bivalent boosters uh compared
to Canada's population
um so unfortunately I can't talk about
the terms of the contracts that um that
we did look at
um they're all within the the seven uh
that that we We examined
um I think the way to control wastage
and to better monitor take up would be
to really Implement all the
functionalities of vaccine connect
um you know the goal was to ensure that
every Canadian who wanted to be
vaccinated could have access to vaccines
and and that was achieved now it's about
minimizing wastage and better inventory
management going forward
and you may not be able to answer this
one but you talked about you've seen the
the terms and conditions most Canadians
have not seen the terms and conditions
are you satisfied that we paid
reasonable prices uh for the vaccines
were we paying prices that were
equal or equivalent to what other
Western countries paid
so it's a difficult question again to
answer if you go back to what the market
looked like back in 2020 when the
negotiations had to take place as I
mentioned earlier no one knew a witch
vaccine companies would be successful no
one knew which vaccines would be
ultimately approved for use in Canada
Canada did not have manufacturing
capabilities for these vaccines so all
of those factors played into the the
prices that were negotiated when it
comes to comparing to other countries
again very difficult most of those
countries one have not made those prices
publicly available but likely had
manufacturing capabilities
um and and so you would expect that they
would pay a different amount than a
country that did not have access to
vaccines so readily
priests from National Post on the line
from a very last question and then a JP
Tasker from CBC and that would be it
Miss Hogan I just wanted to Circle back
to the tables towards the end of your
report so you talked about obviously the
27 odd billion dollars that you said cre
did the investigate even more but then
in the tables at the end you seem to
have
supplemental amount on top of that that
you say should also be investigated but
are even excluded from what I understand
from the 27 billion dollars and that
includes like 1.2 million dollars in
Serb payments to dead people
um or the 6.1 million to people who are
incarcerated when they received it
what's the distinction there why aren't
those amounts in these should be
investigated
but I got suspicious enough what is it
exactly
um well that's exactly why the statement
that I made was that we've identified at
least 27.4 billion dollars in payments
to individuals and businesses that
require further investigation there are
other elements as you say in the in the
back where we talk about each individual
program
um there we were just missing too much
information to either have an audit
level confidence that we should put them
in the 27.4 billion
um or we couldn't really quantify them
um in in a good way so again it's about
missing information and that's why post
payment verification is really the only
way to confirm the actual amounts paid
to ineligible individuals
um and and that's why we recommended
much more rigorous work is needed
JP from CBC yeah I had a very similar
question to Chris there I want you to
kind of talk about that 27.4 billion
figure it's it seems like it's a minimum
right and then there are other sections
that you just couldn't there's other
potential cases of overpayments that you
didn't include in that figure can you
just kind of speak to why those weren't
included and maybe how much they could
be worth again it was it was really
um the uncertainty around some of the
amounts and
um the uh on the missing information so
for example an individual
um who died during the year would have
been eligible for payments up until
their date of death
um and so there is some information that
we didn't have during our audit in order
to make good conclusions right so that's
why we we triage them into different
buckets those that we have a lot more
confidence are are included in the 27.4
billion and then there is further
follow-up up needed for other amounts
both on the individual and business
front
thank you
merciful
thank you everyone this concludes
today's press conference discipline
we've been through a great amount of
questions so that that is how it should
be Mercia Madame verification thank you
to the auditor general have a good day
recording stopped